these characters are going to die it's
unfortunate but confirmed the succession
war will claim both of their lives but
not necessarily in the way that you
think hello and welcome to the new order
of your source for everything anime and
manga my name is liam and i am also
going to die at some point but hopefully
not now and definitely hopefully not in
the way that these guys are because we
are here to break down the future of
chrollo and karapika as just like
crawlers form a lovely ghost writer
ability their futures are both well and
truly logged in hunter hunter even
though they have yet to actually happen
but happen they will and here's how the
first thing that happens is they start
with a quick round of scoop troop a very
simple mini-game the rules of which are
as follows the phantom troop have
started their own ice cream franchise
and it's going to be your job to guess
their flavor of the day should you guess
incorrectly then your punishment will be
to form a nen vow by subscribing to the
new world review which will also result
in consistent injections of hunter-based
culture being administered directly into
your youtube feed and if you are correct
then you will win a free ice cream but
which flavor will it be munchie mango
chrollo and cookies or peanut butter
thinks make your choice now and we shall
reveal the answer in three two one and
bam it was matchy mango very refreshing
for the summer weather which you're
probably not experiencing at this time
of year but i am because i am australian
but if you guessed incorrectly then you
know the thing to do and please do say
hi in the comments below if you are a
new member of the association welcome so
let's talk about unfinished business
that really could be the name of this
entire series actually because this
brand of incomplete transaction appears
everywhere in hunt hunter however
karapika and the phantom troupe are
quite a special case from what we know
of the series retrospectively it appears
that this connection is very much
wrapped up after york new city but
that's just because we know that the two
parties haven't actually met again and
we've gotten distracted by all sorts of
things like video games elections and of
course anthropomorphic ants but
krapika's final words regarding the
troop are quite revealing i hate to
leave my business with the spiders
unfinished but it's been two days
they've probably left by now and the
eyes of my brethren should come first
meaning that krapika rather reluctantly
gave up on hunting the troop on this
particular occasion prioritizing
recovery of the curtain rise and yes
there's all sorts of themes in york new
city with krapika coming to terms with
the fact that the troops are not quite
the genocidal monsters he assumed they'd
be and in reality they're a lot more
human than anyone would like to admit
considering their horrific actions and
throughout this discussion one thing
we're going to have to come to terms
with is that crolo and karapica are
actually extraordinarily similar to one
another with the first of those being
that each of them has committed great
atrocities in the name of others with
crolo everything he does is for the good
of the troop and or meteor city and with
karapika everything he's done is for the
sake of his clan both characters very
much thrust into the darkest underbelly
of the hunt hunter world out of sheer
necessity or at least a perceived
necessity and there's many many many
more where that came from but for now
york new city was an awfully long time
ago and as i love to point out every
single chance i get togashi's
motivations and ideas have changed
radically throughout the years just
because he set up something during an
arc in the year 2001 doesn't mean that
he's still necessarily on track with
that two decades later in 2021 which by
the way happy 20th birthday york new
city arc you are so much older than i
thought you were but while togashi's
scatter brained improvisation strategy
does prevail for the most part karapika
and the troop are a very rare exception
which is proved by the existence of
hunter hunter volume 0 which provides
the events of the kurta clan massacre
but there is also a fun interview with
togashi within this volume where he is
asked why he made it in the first place
with that answer being i want to draw
the relationship slash conflict between
the phantom troop and karapika starting
from their origins i thought i would be
able to finish it quickly and i was able
to finish karapik as quickly but shortly
after a lot happened and i ended up
having to shelve it which is a
fascinating yet cryptic message what
togashi makes absolutely clear is that
he never lost sight of the krapika
phantom true plotline particularly since
volume 0 came out 12 years after york
new city ended and rather
uncharacteristically all of this time
later togashi was still hell-bent on
telling a particular story and he admits
that quote a lot happened referring to
greed island chimera ants chairman
elections and the most recently at that
time commenced dark continent r which is
important because that timing is
everything the release of this volume
telling the story if krapika's past
happened at the exact moment that both
karapika and the phantom troop became
focal points of the dark continent
events and given that togashi said he
had shelved their story following
yorknew this seems like a pretty
convenient time to dust that story off
which we do have evidence of courtesy of
mr mizeistom in chapter 381 after
discovering illumi and color to aboard
the blackwell one mizei storm
immediately craps his mental pantaloons
at the very thought of krapika learning
of the troops presence thus potentially
setting up a thread between the two
factions going forward which is a very
natural path to collision they're on
very different missions right now the
crawler's ultimate goal here is to rob
the khakian royal family a family that
krapika is currently contracted to
protect or at least protect one of them
the small one so all going well for the
phantom troop they will encounter
karapaka at some point however that very
much depends on your definition of the
word well because in that very same
interview in volume zero togashi quite
literally stated the ultimate fates of
both krapika and the troop which is they
will all die and i have said this before
but it's really hard to judge the
context of this statement it may very
well be a joke that doesn't translate
well between languages and especially on
paper but it could certainly be a
serious response as well in fact that's
very much what we need to take it as by
default because we have no discernible
evidence of humor how are they going to
die though well for most of the troop
it's unlikely to be cropper caused
because currently hisoka is bungle
nutting his way around the blackwell one
with the intention of hunting and
killing each and every member of the
troop furthermore they're also embroiled
in all sorts of mafia power struggles on
the lower decks and in particular they
are set up against morena and her
followers who will eventually reach an
insane quantity of power thanks to
morena's video game leveling and ability
they're in a bad spot a very bad spot
especially if they continue to be
separated the greatest strength of the
troop is being able to act as a
collective in any given situation one of
them will have the utility skill
required for a mission to succeed but
fractured they are very vulnerable
especially in a confined space filled
almost exclusively with other trained
men using killing dudes but to zero in
on kroller for a bit here is our big
twist right now he's hunting hisoka for
the crimes of murdering cortopian shanna
crollo has put his royalty robbing
mission to one side simply for the task
of delivering sweet revenge upon hisoka
revenge for your murdered loved ones
does that sound familiar to anyone else
prollo is in the exact spot that his
actions placed karapika in the troop
murdered the kurt clan and karapika
swore revenge on the spiders now members
of crollo's little clan have been
brutally murdered and he has sworn
revenge on the person clown man
responsible which actually makes it very
difficult to feel any kind of sympathy
for crawler while the phantom trooper
large because they're just experiencing
a dose of the torment that their actions
have been causing all along unless
you're takashi of course because he
actually quite admires crawler and in
fact crawler was his favorite member of
the troop allegedly because of his
selfless nature this was also revealed
in volume 0 but togashi holds a deep
distrust of elected officials as well as
leaders in general people who in his
words nominate themselves for leadership
meanwhile crolo is a man who was elected
by the founding troop members and
regardless of what his deeds are
everything he enacts is for the
betterment of the group as opposed to
his own personal benefit something that
karapika realizes in chapter 117 when he
says i assume the spiders would fall
apart once their head was removed but
that's not how they work the spiders
keep going even without their head so as
twisted as it is crolo is a selfless
antagonist and from his perspective
probably a protagonist he cares much
more for those around him than he does
for himself but we've now gotten a taste
of his darker side during the succession
war and that's just the result of two
members dying so what would happen in
the event where everyone died leaving
crollow all alone the spider head
without his spider legs well that's my
prediction i think that on this path
towards everyone dying at some stage
crollo will be the last surviving member
of the troop perfectly mirroring
karapika's situation with the kurt clan
and at this stage down the line is when
karapika will encounter crolo and he
will have a decision to make the only
trouble being that krapika may have to
continue his journey of mental growth
back in york new city he came to terms
with the fact that the troop were a
community of their own they have their
own rules practically their own society
and their own personal care for one
another not too far from the idea of a
traveling clan and as twistedly painful
as it may be grapika could be put in a
situation where he legitimately
empathizes with kroller which i imagine
would only further enrage garoppolo i
mean the thought of empathizing with the
man who ordered the slaughter of your
entire village for the sake of making a
bit of money but that's the kind of
stark confrontation that togashi handles
absolutely masterfully the best example
we currently have of such mental
conflicts would obviously be the chimera
ants a lot of that arc was very much
about questioning who the real monsters
were during this time we saw human
characters devolve into unfeeling brutal
monsters and we saw literal ant monsters
develop into highly sympathetic human
existences so a similar swap would
certainly be possible with kraftwicker
and krollo except in this case we would
just be flipping around the role of the
victim which actually provides karapika
with quite possibly his only chance for
redemption if he were to encounter
crollo recognize a cycle of revenge and
then decide to break it or at the very
least not participate in it any further
and we've been talking a lot about
krapika's feelings but crawler's
perspective is also very important here
because in the event that he meets with
karapika he will also be able to
empathize with and perhaps even take
responsibility for what he's done or at
least offer a gesture of apology before
promptly removing himself from this
world which is one of our numerous
endgame options for kroller with his
legs entirely dismembered he may just
decide to end it all because who is he
going to go on fighting for another is
that crawler lets revenge fully consume
him and his life comes to a fiery
conclusion perhaps in some kind of
hisoka-based battle and this could also
work because it would give karapika a
tangible example of his own future fate
should he continue down this path and
then give him that last minute chance to
jump out meanwhile you could also go a
bit weirder and focus on crolo's keen
reference to jesus he invert a cross on
his back the collective of twelve
disciples and so on and so forth he's
very jesus-y which holds the potential
of perhaps crawler sacrificing himself
for the sake of the troop in very much
the same way that mr jesus died on a
cross for all of all of the people which
may not play into togashi's words about
everyone dying so nicely but it doesn't
exclude the option because they can
still die and be brought back hisoka is
a prime example of that he quite
literally died and then brought himself
back from death maybe hisoka here's the
jesus but given that crolo can mix and
match every inability he comes across i
would not put it past him to conjure up
a nen resurrection spell at the cost of
his own life it does seem like a very
crowley thing to do sacrifice the head
so that the legs can live and in keeping
with religious theming perhaps even ask
forgiveness from karapika because when
it comes down to it what we have is an
eventual clash that togashi has never
lost sight of a story he feels he needs
to tell which involves two young men
geniuses or genie i what's the plural of
genius you know what i don't care two
young nen genie i both specialists as
well with a complex suite of swiss army
style and abilities both of whom are
thrust into tragedy at a young age
through no fault of their own and both
of them now doing what they feel is in
the best interest of their respective
groups and both of them set to become
the last remaining member of their clans
but i do feel that the ultimate decision
will rest with grapika this is his story
after all and for better or worse his
choice to make he can suffer revenge or
he can suffer redemption neither will be
particularly easy and in the ominous
words of yoshihiro tagashi it will very
very likely cost his life either way
probably worth it though as is this next
video because there's always more to
learn explored experience with this
wonderful series so i look forward to
seeing you there